the New York Post reports on a so-called
redneck rescue mission their words by
three people who tried to enter New York
City with an arsenal of weapons handguns
and a rifle were found during a routine
traffic stop outside the Holland Tunnel
officers also found ammunition and
tactical gear inside this very
distinctive truck the suspects posted
these pictures shortly before their
arrest they reportedly claimed that they
were on a mission to save a life Don
Dahler is on the New Jersey side of the
Holland Tunnel with a very bizarre
investigation Don good morning good
morning the investigation is still under
way but authorities have ruled out
terrorism in this particular case one of
the suspects taken into custody John
cramsey has a background though that
reveals a personal story of loss that
may have been what preceded this
ill-advised rescue attempt the Port
Authority police stopped this hard to
miss vehicle early Tuesday morning on
the New Jersey side of the Holland
Tunnel
here's the situation where you have a
crack windshield on a car the police
officer pulls the car over and sees a
loaded magazine on the on the floor of
the car and that's probable cause that
starts the whole investigation a search
inside the colorful truck revealed a
small Arsenal including multiple
handguns one assault rifle body armor
knives night-vision goggles and multiple
rounds of ammunition a large majority of
these weapons were loaded police say the
group claims they were traveling from
Pennsylvania to New York to rescue a
teenager being held against her will one
of the people arrested includes 50 year
old John cramsey the owner of higher
ground tactical item a gun range in
Pennsylvania higher ground tactical
shooting training instruction cramsey
has been something of an anti-drug
advocate after his 20 year old daughter
alexandria reportedly died from an
overdose of heroin and fentanyl back in
February
he helps start this Facebook page enough
is enough and posted this message to
Facebook shortly before he was arrested
going to a hotel to extract a 16 year
old girl adding her friend died of
another heroin overdose I'm bringing her
out of New York today and anybody else
in that hotel that wants to go home to a
friend of cramsey Michael Nikki sure
believes the death of his daughter
prompted this vigilante act ever since
his daughter died I think it was one of
those things where he wishes he could
have done something to save her and now
that she's gone he feels his guilt in
his heart that he needs to help other
people
our CBS station here in New York says
that the sixteen-year-old girl said that
she was not being held against her will
but that she was in need of assistance
last night the NYPD took her into
custody
Nora there is a silver lining there
touching frightening at the same time a
great scary when I first heard about
that new Don thank you so much